president biden returning from his trip
overseas empty-handed and in a world of
trouble he secured no major oil deal
after fist bumping with the saudis he's
facing brutal new poll numbers and the
first lady is making pathetic excuses
for his failing presidency dr jill biden
taking a break from comparing hispanics
to tacos
and justifying joe's lack of progress in
his presidency saying this
the president had so many hopes and
plans for things he wanted to do but
every time he turned around he had to
address the problems of the moment he's
just had so many things thrown his way
who would have ever thought about what
happened with the supreme court
overturning roe v wade well maybe we saw
it coming but still we didn't believe it
it's no wonder she's forced to make
excuses for her deeply unpopular husband
with the majority of voters expecting
the economy to go from bad to worse next
year meanwhile democrats in the media
are turning their backs on biden after
his controversial fist bump with the
saudi crown prince watch
you have a
leader of that country
who was involved in the murder of a
washington post journalist i don't think
that that type of government should be
rewarded with a visit by the president
of the united states going from calling
mps a pariah to fist pumping him
was really disappointing
um this whole trip
sends the wrong message i don't think
that biden gets a pass just because he's
a democrat just because uh that he's a
democratic president he's fist bumping
this guy who is clearly a murderer
dana is it time to put jill in a timeout
because last week she calls hispanics
tacos and then she goes and tells donors
joe failed and you know he didn't see
anything coming i think every time i
hear the jill biden comments read and i
realize that it's in the past tense that
really is interesting so she's at a big
donor fundraiser in nantucket which has
been that's pretty much like anybody
want to give a million dollars you can
you can basically do that up there and
she's basically saying the presidency is
kind of over and there was no hope there
was no but we've got this and here's
what we're going to do and you've got to
be with us but maybe she did that in
other parts of the speech but if you're
sitting there and that's the part that
you take away then
you realize that they must have some
tough conversations at home
i think they're going to have tougher
conversations as it gets closer to the
midterms when we can see what's going to
happen those things are tightening a
little bit as usual that's what happens
around this time of year
but then you're going to have an even
bigger conversation after the midterms
after thanksgiving when which is when i
believe that the president is going to
make a very tough decision we might see
something quite historic the other thing
that happened this weekend is that
bernie sanders is basically saying that
joe manchin killed joe biden's agenda so
well actually no sir
joe biden was trying to do your agenda
bernie sanders agenda and that's what's
gotten the
democrats into a terrible fix now and
all of a sudden bernie sanders is going
to go out on all the shows
and criticize
the joe manchin and not realize that the
consequences of their actions that i
think is pretty interesting the last
thing i would say is that the reality is
right now the
activists are running the asylum at the
white house not necessarily the white
house staff themselves but if you look
at what kate bettingfield the outgoing
communications director said about the
activist class that you're not even
really a democrat you're not on our side
they have problems not just with
independents and women and the youth
vote and hispanic vote and the black
vote they have problems with the
progressive vote and now they're even
having problems with their own moderates
when that many people don't want the
president to run again it's a huge
problem and they're mad that he fist
bumped the saudi crown prince
i don't you know i don't even care about
that i think that's just silly
silly stuff i mean there are bad people
all over the world you got to deal with
and that's you know what are you going
to do punch him in the face i do love
how you know you got inflation you got
war you got crime but the real victim
here is joe
you know
i mean it would be nice not to have
inflation not to be uh uh uh supporting
a war with billions not to be riddled
with crime for america's sake for our
sake
not because the president is not shining
as a valuable leader but it is a
remarkable confession on her part she's
basically saying that her husband was
not the man for the moment you know uh i
don't think she meant it that way but
it's like you know god if it wasn't for
these challenges
it would have been great well
a jar of pickles would be great if there
were no challenges you know the present
you know history makes the makes the
leader right and the president's role is
to is to respond to crisis and
challenges it's not to chase easy pet
pet pro
pet projects it was a long
weekend during times of prosperity it's
kind of an interesting thing it's like
they rely on the left relies on
republicans to kind of keep things going
so then they can
chase the folly the pronouns the
silliness but now they have to put all
their silliness on hold because all the
real problems are falling apart under
joe and they're kind of upset by that
why don't they just deal with the
problems i'm just disappointed in you
know dr jill being a medical doctor and
not being able to solve this problem but
you know he's the consummate coaster
bear he's been the backslapping kind of
consultant living off the fat of the
taxpayer dollar he doesn't want to work
and that's the shame he's like this is
supposed to be easy yeah i mean imagine
bush said
so many plans for privatizing social
security and then we got hit on 911. you
can't say that if you're president you
know what i love about this team it was
jill biden who took joe around during
the pandemic and made sure that nobody
got near him that they could hide in the
basement and they had their masks on and
you know there were cars beeping and
supporting joe well trump was out there
with 30 35 000 people uh at a time but i
love and and permit me i just love the
but the problems of the moment prevented
him from doing what he so wanted to do
and didn't do for 47 years in in
government so for example the supreme
court overturning roe versus wade jill
you had six weeks from the time it
leaked to the time the actual decision
came out that's not a moment that's six
weeks all right so i don't know what
you're complaining about there and then
she talks about the
the problems of the moment leaving
afghanistan where 13 people died who
never should have died 13 service men
and women was not a problem at the
moment he knew from the day he walked in
he had to have a plan to get out of
afghanistan and by the way you didn't
see ukraine coming are you kidding from
january when zielinski asked to get into
nato and he started amassing troops at
the border people were taking bets you
think he's going in nah he's not going
in yeah i think he's building up he's
building up troops now he is and he
isn't this guy biden has had weeks and
months to decide what he's going to do
he is incapable of doing what he needs
to do and let me say one more thing i
don't believe joe biden i don't believe
that joe biden got up there and said you
know gave him a what for on khashoggi
i'm not saying that i believe the other
guy from saudi arabia who said he didn't
hear it but this is what's interesting
joe said he talked about oil and he
talked about increasing the opec
increasing their oil now what we saw a
couple weeks ago was when macron the
president of france spoke to joe biden
and jake sullivan said let's take it
inside when macron said to biden they're
not going to pump any more oil he
already knew going in there he wasn't
going to get any more oil so
you know i i when the foreign minister
says they never even raised the issue of
supply you know i i just got a problem
the guy is a mess he's not up to the job
and that's the end all right jessica
convince us that we're all wrong
okay i have like 80 seconds i think i
heard in my ear
um
so first of all i think it was
kirby the spokesperson came out and said
that they weren't going for an oil deal
in this visit it'll be at opec plus
which is coming up um in a few weeks
we'll see what's not urgent right now
that was you want to wait a few weeks
take with it what you will we've seen
almost a 40 cent drop in the in the
gallon price
of oil over the last month if it stays
on this route by mid august we'll be
under four dollars a gallon it won't be
but it's not going to because the cost
of the barrels have gone up you just
told me
those are the facts of what happened
here um i was not a fan of the trip to
saudi i don't think it sends the right
message um fist bumper no fist bump i
though would say i would never take the
word of a saudi foreign minister over
the president of the united states of
america he says he raised it there was a
statement from jamal khashoggi's wife
thanking president biden for doing that
that was something that certainly didn't
get from the last administration any
sense of accountability the mention of
human rights which was jamal khashoggi's
mission in life to raise attention to
what goes on um and
human rights catastrophes in terms of
what jill biden i hope was talking about
at this fundraiser beyond those comments
which i thought it was weird as well
that it was in past tense um
you got the american rescue package you
had a bipartisan infrastructure bill
which was a huge accomplishment you had
bipartisan gun reform something that has
completely eluded democratic presidents
going back to the 90s when obviously we
had the assault weapons ban those are
real accomplishments that i think
history will look back and i'm not
saying that people are going to say joe
biden was the greatest president of our
time we will say there were real things
that were accomplished and he got mitch
mcconnell to sign off on them and if you
know anything about mitch mcconnell you
know that he doesn't do anything that he
really doesn't want to do
and you know that it's hard to get him
to agree with you what pisses me off
though is this comments about we didn't
see roe v wade coming people have been
screaming this from the rooftop since
2016 when ruth bader ginsburg decided
that she did not want to resign and step
down barack obama met with her he did
not say ruth you got to get out of here
but he certainly raised the issue that
we don't know what's going to happen in
2016. and people on the pro-choice side
activists and just normal people have
been worried about this happening
because
the fate of abortion care in this
country women's reproductive health care
is in the hands of these judges and you
can say it just gets kicked back to the
states i know how it works but we've
also seen just three weeks of this the
implications for women on the ground who
are crossing state lines in order to get
care who have doctors waiting too long
to give them treatments that are still
remain legal because they are afraid of
losing their medical licenses and that's
the real world implications of this so
don't say we didn't see this coming it's
too important of an issue that your
advisors had been talking to you about
to push that kick that down the road so
okay i'm glad you got that off your
chest
coming up after a terrifying string of
attacks liberal leaders are getting
called out for putting violent offenders
ahead of law-abiding citizens hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now